sometimes when you're trying to make
that transition you're on two surfboards
but you can't ride them both at the same
time it's impossible
how many years was it between
showing at sundance
and getting your first television
directing job
so i went to sundance in january of 2001
i booked my first episode of television
in april
of
20
17.
oh wow okay
so that would be
16
and a quarter
but you were active
in film and television you worked at nyu
for a while
yeah i mean that whole time so to anyone
everyone watching and listening i never
stopped being a filmmaker and i think
you know that's part of what i try and
touch on in the book like you're
you have to define yourself you have to
claim what you what you are and who you
are and so while i work the desk job at
nyu i was assistant production
coordinator i was signing forms for the
students to go
get film and
you know
rent equipment or here's a voucher to go
to kodak or whatever i was
this i was the signature toward other
younger folks dreams
you know um i answered
a
million questions at the window because
they would come to our window and and
get this information and i would you
know give
uh
unsolicited advice or
it became
sought after people would kind of know
that i had
a real world skill that i could kind of
impart and offer to them
i was
you know i had my production company
during this time i had a podcast
um
you know i was making things i won a
competition at tribeca for a heist
screenplay that i co-wrote in 2008
i wrote a bunch of screenplays i thought
i might sell that i never did and so
all of that time i was still
creating
trying to i had i had a i had a target
on feature filmmaking
because that was what i had
gotten into
this game to do you know
um
and
over time
you know this landscape was changing it
was the the the types of films that i
was kind of interested in making were
becoming
uh
obsolete because everything was coming
from some other intellectual property
like a comic book or an amusement park
ride like pirates of the caribbean you
know and like
20 million dollar films 10 million
dollar films were kind of disappearing
and
what i was noticing was a lot of the
people that i wanted that i
was inspired by that made those films
were moving the tv
because that's where
there was more uh
there was a a a higher need there they
needed more they needed more content
um and
the filmmakers that were kind of sent to
the wayside by the new mandate and
features were going over to tv and
saying well
i'd love to tell that kind of story and
obviously all ushered in by sopranos in
the golden age and
watching these interesting characters
find exploration episode after episode
season after season
and so um
for
yeah i think from like 0-9 until 2017 i
had a pretty
pretty
dedicated focus on trying to get into tv
um
but it took some time before i was able
to kind of
put it all together
did you ever feel this sort of common
thing that someone took your chance you
know i see it in our comments and and i
can understand why people get angry but
did you ever feel that at times
no i just felt i never thought i never
felt like someone took my chance i
i was constantly trying to find the
cocktail
that would work for me
to
[Music]
get the opportunity
and you know
what was clear and i'm a person who went
through
four director programs that
um the studios and the networks were
compelled to put together
um because the hiring was so
um
clearly angled in one direction
um you know
i just felt like well how do i get
access to the people you know who are
making these decisions i felt like that
would be
the big that i knew that that was the
biggest hurdle and so that that hurdle
was either
making something that people could see
and doing that as often as possible um
to give myself as many shots as possible
and then also
discovering these programs where you
would get to learn how television was
made and be included in these
cohorts and these units that were
selected
to
help bridge the gap between
you know
93 of the directors being hired being
white males and 7
encompassed everyone else
um and so those pipelines were helpful
in kind of meeting the folks learning
how tv was made and then
um
you know hopefully
shining enough to to get the
opportunities
did anybody sit you down and say pete i
know you mean well but like why don't
you
have you thought about going to law
school
no right guy no nobody ever sat me down
or tried to send me in another direction
i you know i feel like
i was
i never had
i always had
people
share
maybe not the the the the strength of
belief in me but i feel like everybody
in my world
believed in me because
it was clear that i was being very
thoughtful about it
it wasn't like
you know i didn't have like
delusions of grandeur of like what it
was
going to take from me to get in the
industry
um i was informed on how it worked
um
when i
met a roadblock i tried to
hop up to 10 000 feet and look at it and
then say well what can i learn from this
and how can i pivot you know which is
kind of the whole like through line of
the book
you know it's like there's these you're
gonna
you're gonna have your everybody's gonna
have their own journey and their own
story but like
you're gonna find
opportunities in these challenges and
and you have to
challenge yourself to respond
with your goal in mind and not with your
emotion and not with your
you know
you know anything else
is this your quote right here pete
uh yeah i said it may i i'll take
ownership i know maybe someone else has
said it somewhere in the world but
yeah if you ride the wave long enough
the tide always turns
and what does that mean
to me that just is
it means a lot of things i and it's
funny i have a lot of water metaphors uh
like in the book i talked about
being a yacht
you know in the road to getting your
first job you're like this luxury yacht
that doesn't have a slip to dock
and
you're trying to build enough awareness
in the marina for people to offer you a
slip so you can get off the boat and
walk on land you know
um and then another one that i i say
often is um
you know
sometimes when you're trying to make
that transition you're on two surfboards
but you can't ride them both at the same
time it's impossible and
the reality of that is you're gonna have
to choose which one you're gonna get on
you can't ride them both you're gonna
have to pick one and step off of one in
order to get to where you're going
and so you know this quote
if you why if you ride the wave long
enough the tide always turns um
is speaking to the idea of
you know
for those of you who are
trying and have been trying to go after
a singular goal
um
i can't remove
being self-aware
and i can't remove being um
uh
you know being smart about the business
and
uh being
open to feedback
but if you take those three things and
include that as kind of the back
the back end of this of this quote
i think that
over a long enough timeline with those
three things um powering you
you'll find your
can it mean though that there can also
be a reversal of fortune
yeah i think i think exactly there can
definitely be a reversal you can it you
know if you're seeing
you know hit after hit after hit or
you know everybody loves everything you
do every time that you release it or you
do it
it's
probably going to come a time where it's
not going to be as well received
and then at that point you know i think
then it just flips to the other side
and then you
figure out how to how to get out of that
situation but
um
you know
what do they say even a broken clock is
right two times a day
you know like it's just
i i i've found over my journey that
having things that remind me of
um
it's not destiny or it's not
predetermined or it's not like
you know um
i'm not in some kind of
i can't think of the word i'm looking
for
um i'm not in some kind of like career
purgatory you know what i mean like
there's ways to
navigate the down times
and most of it's going to be about
having a positive attitude